en este vídeo nos vamos a enfocar más en
la idea de la evolución ya hemos
introducido esta idea en otros vídeos
pero aquí nos vamos a enfocar más en lo
que es y en lo que no es y como he
mencionado anteriormente es una idea
súper importante si intentaras entender
la vida en otro planeta
bueno tendrías que entender cómo
funciona la evolución y la evolución
como la conocemos se basa en dos
principios fundamentales se basa en un
principio de que en una población de
especies hay variación hay variación en
el fenotipo en los rasgos que tiene esa
población ahora la otra idea que está
relacionada con esa variación es que
tienes selección natural selección
natural si alguien trata de explicar
evolución sin variación y sin selección
natural probablemente no estará
explicando evolución probablemente
estará explicando otra cosa de modo que
esta idea si tengo una población de
círculos algunos círculos son azules
algunos son amarillos círculos amarillos
algunos son círculos rosas y con
seguridad existen rasgos existen
fenotipos que pueden no tener ninguna
relación con la capacidad de un
organismo para sobrevivir o reproducirse
en ese caso es probable que esa
variación continúe recuerden los
fenotipos son lo que se expresa frente a
los genotipos que son los genes reales
los alelos reales que tiene un organismo
pero la evolución ocurre porque
dependiendo de donde estemos en nuestro
entorno en el espacio y tiempo de
nuestro entorno
ciertos fenotipos probablemente sean un
poco más ventajosos que otros podrían
hacer que sea más probable que el
organismo sobreviva y se reproduzca es
menos probable que mueran o que no pueda
reproducirse y si dijéramos que estos
círculos son seres vivos y digamos que
en el entorno en que están ahora es
mucho más probable que se reproduzcan y
sobrevivan si son de colores más cálidos
si son anaranjados o rosas frente a los
azules por lo que en la siguiente
generación es más probable que los
amarillos y los rosas se reproduce
así que se van a reproducir un poco más
déjenme poner otros rosas aquí se van a
reproducir un poco más y los azules
podrían tener una menor probabilidad de
reproducirse con base en esta situación
que describí de modo que tendrás azules
pero serán menos azules y luego este
proceso se puede mantener por un tiempo
muy muy largo y en algún punto
probablemente sólo veas rosas y
amarillos y este es solo un fenotipo que
se puede seleccionar del que estamos
hablando puede haber otro si estamos
hablando de círculos podría ser redondez
o cualquier otra cosa entonces la clave
es que necesitas esa variación y
dependiendo de en qué momento y espacio
te encuentres en ese entorno algunas de
esas variaciones algunos de esos
fenotipos los rasgos exhibidos podrían
hacerte más exitoso reproduciendo y
transmitiendo ese rasgo a tu
descendencia y realmente quiero
contrastar esto con lo que algunas
personas consideran cuando piensan en la
evolución
algunas personas consideran que la
evolución es un proceso en el que se
pasa de lo básico a lo avanzado y la
razón por la que a veces pensamos esto
es porque pensamos que muchos de los
primeros organismos en la tierra podrían
haber sido organismos unicelulares y
ahora tenemos estos animales complejos
como nosotros mismos que consideramos
que somos mucho más avanzados que estas
cosas tenemos trillones de células pero
recuerda los organismos unicelulares
continúan siendo muy exitosos incluso
ahora y algunos de ellos no son más
avanzados que las cosas que podrían
haber existido digamos hace 500 millones
de años o incluso hace mil millones de
años y aunque estas cosas pueden ser el
producto de la evolución lo que
significa es que a través del tiempo
tienes esa variación y luego con base en
qué variaciones que fenotipos se
adecuaron más a su entorno esas son las
que pudieron pasar sus rasgos
otro lugar de donde proviene este
concepto erróneo es que has visto estos
días que tienen estos simios donde los
primeros están encorvados
y luego se ponen de pie o más y más
erguidos y eventualmente ves una persona
caminando y oficialmente también somos
monos y tendemos a pensar que somos
bastante avanzados y hacemos cosas como
usar sombrero y otras cosas y entonces
decimos o si esto va de lo primitivo a
lo avanzado o de lo básico a lo avanzado
pero ese no es el caso recuerda que
incluso en el mundo de hoy no somos el
fin de la evolución incluso en nuestro
mundo hay muchos animales en el reino
animal que están en diferentes niveles
de complejidad o si queremos pensar en
la inteligencia sofisticación y sin duda
podría haber una realidad en la que
puedas imaginar que una colonia humana
se dirige a otro planeta y en realidad
es adecuado estar más encorvado en cuyo
caso las variaciones de los humanos que
son mejores para encorvarse podrían ser
más exitosos
quizás necesiten ir a esos túneles para
encontrar algunos animales para comer o
lo que sea o para cultivar y luego en
ese planeta esa variación podría ser la
que gane ahora otra idea equivocada que
las personas tienen en relación con la
evolución es cuando lo escuchan piensan
que eso podría deberse al esfuerzo de un
animal a lo largo de su vida algunas de
las primeras explicaciones que la gente
dio antes de darwin de por qué una
jirafa por ejemplo tiene un cuello largo
algunas personas creen que algunas de
las jirafas primitivas podrían haber
estado esforzándose por obtener hojas en
árboles altos y por ese esfuerzo de
alguna manera estiraron sus cuellos y de
alguna manera podrían haber sido capaces
de transmitir eso a su descendencia este
no es el caso
la explicación consiste en nuestra
comprensión de la evolución en que
hubieras tenido una población de
ancestros de jirafas y habrían tenido
variaciones en sus longitudes de cuello
y debido al ambiente en el que se
encontraba esa población la variación
que tenía longitudes de cuello más
largas
podría haber tenido una probabilidad
ligeramente mayor de reproducirse y
sobrevivir y a través del tiempo los de
cuello largo se volvieron más
predominantes en la población y en algún
punto podrías decir porque los cuellos
de las jirafas no se vuelven
indefinidamente altos bueno eso es
porque algunas variaciones que tenían
cuellos super largos incluso más largos
que las jirafas que tenemos hoy podrían
haber tenido otras dificultades que
hicieron difícil su supervivencia y
reproducción tal vez sus corazones no
eran lo suficientemente fuertes y
murieron de ataques al corazón o tal vez
le era más difícil escapar de los
depredadores a la variación que tenía
los cuellos demasiado largos entonces es
realmente importante reconocer que la
evolución es un subproducto de la
variación que ocurre en las poblaciones
y luego la selección natural debido al
medio ambiente en esas variaciones y
actúan sobre el fenotipo actúan sobre
los rasgos que se muestran la evolución
no es necesariamente un proceso que va
de lo básico a lo avant
y no se debe a que un organismo
individual de alguna manera se ejercite
o se entrene para el entorno en el que
se encuentra hasta el próximo vídeo